it stands taller than the statue of
liberty signaling the dawn of a new era
in space exploration the aim of nasa's
artemis program to return humans to the
moon
it's one small step for man
with the orion command capsule at the
center this is the most powerful rocket
ever built
its maiden voyage an unmanned test
mission overseen by a new generation of
engineers
they're very wide-eyed and and doing
again a fantastic job we have some
extremely smart people that have come up
very quickly through the ranks to to get
the positions that they now hold in the
firing room and we have trained and
trained to get them to the level
so that they would be ready to support
this launch countdown and everybody has
to have a first one right and this is
going to be the first for for a great
number of people in that room we're
going to the moon
if all goes to plan they hope to land
the first woman and first person of
color on the moon by 2025
keeping america ahead of china we're in
a space race
and
we want to get to the south pole of the
moon where the resources are where we
think water is if there's water there's
rocket fuel
and we don't want china suddenly getting
there and saying
ah this is our exclusive territory
it's a quarter of a million miles to the
moon and artemis one will go 40 000
miles beyond that
further than any spacecraft equipped to
carry humans has gone before
but even that is just the start of this
journey nasa hopes to establish a
permanent moon base the first step to
putting humans on mars
nasa has registered thousands of watch
parties here in america and around the
world it'll be the most consequential
liftoff in a generation and artemis one
is go for launch
david blevins sky news cape canaveral
florida